joueuse de harpe maniement les âmes ou
poterie d'antan plongée au coeur du 15e
siècle dans le cadre des journées
européennes du patrimoine un village
médiéval ait installé au pied du donjon
ne mord pas l'occasion de découvrir la
vie quotidienne de nos ancêtres
nous avons donc retracer un peu
l'histoire bas de maurepas voyage
nous avons fait un jeu sur les temps du
moyen-âge donc petits et grands peuvent
participer
nous avons les arts plastiques qui vont
faire des des épées des hommes pour les
enfants des activités pour les enfants
nous avons les compteurs du bois joli
aussi clean on que font des comptes en
partenariat avec la ville et
l'association mort pas d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui les regrattiers d'histoire
font découvrir leurs spécialités aux
visiteurs marcus occupe du logis
explique l'utilité des différents
ustensiles pour la table et son métier
de dégraisseur je parcours les rues de
paris notamment en criant allah
maletache donc en criant des mendiants
al amal tâches comme ça comprenez donc à
la mauvaise tâche la tâche rebelles
celles qui résistent sur les vêtements
et donc je ged ces dames ou qui n'arrive
pas à le nettoyer leurs loges et à se
défaire des tâches sur leurs futurs
combats d'épées dépaysement garanti une
période qui fascine toujours petits et
grands bah on a déjà fait les chapeaux
pour les filles
et puis après on va regarder un petit
peu tous qui a aux alentours dans les
tentes à droite à gauche et puis on
verra bien là on a fait un peu de harpe
et fine c'est sympathique c'est joli ce
qu'ils mettaient leur coiffe tout ça et
pillent les fabriqués avec du tissu
très belles choses du coup c'est
vraiment un joli retour au moyen-âge le
temps d'un week-end les festivités se
sont terminées dimanche